-L'engagement tient parfois
à peu de choses.
Mon invité ne serait peut-être
jamais devenu député
sans sa nounou
et sans les gilets jaunes.
Générique
...
-Bonjour,
Philippe Brun.
Je parlais
de votre nounou.
C'est pas tous les jours
qu'on parle des nounous
des politiques.
Je vous laisse nous la présenter.
-Elle s'appelle Josette.
C'est une ancienne
marinière qui a travaillé
sur les bateaux sur la Seine.
Elle habite Poses, dans l'Eure,
un des villages dans lesquels
j'ai grandi.
Quand elle me gardait,
elle nous faisait voir,
avec mon frère et ma soeur,
"Les questions au gouvernement",
le mercredi après-midi.
On regardait le JT de 13h
de Jean-Pierre Pernaut
après "Les feux de l'amour",
et puis à 15h, "Les questions
au gouvernement" sur France 3.
J'avais entre 8 et 10 ans.
-Ca vous intéressait ?
-Oui, quand on explique,
c'est compréhensible, la politique.
Il y a plein de choses
qu'on comprend, on parle
des situations des gens.
En enfant de 8 ou 9 ans ne comprend
pas tout au premier abord,
mais elle m'expliquait les choses.
Jean-Louis Debré était président
de l'Assemblée, député d'Evreux,
pas loin de chez moi.
Donc j'étais heureux de regarder ça
et j'avais envie de passer
de l'autre côté
de la télévision.
-Votre nounou vous a éveillé
à la politique
pendant que vos camarades de classe
collectionnaient les vignettes
Panini de jouer de foot.
Ca se traduisait comment,
cette passion ?
-J'ai jamais eu
de poster de politique
dans ma chambre,
mais j'étais un gamin
un peu particulier.
Je lisais Le Monde
vers 12 ou 13 ans,
je m'abonnais
à tout un tas de revues,
j'étais passionné par la politique,
et finalement,
les meilleurs moments
de mon enfance, c'est
les Coupes du monde de foot
et les présidentielles.
-C'est l'équivalent ?
-Voilà.
-Ca, c'est votre éveil
à la politique.
Si on s'intéresse à votre engagement
politique, l'élément déclencheur,
ça a été, d'une certaine façon,
les gilets jaunes, fin 2018.
Alors à l'époque,
vous étiez diplômé de HEC,
tout juste diplômé de l'ENA,
et ça peut paraître étonnant,
mais vous êtes allé
sur les ronds-points.
Pourquoi ?
-On est en novembre 2018
et je sortais de l'ENA.
On a eu notre classement
à ce moment-là.
On n'a pas encore d'affectation,
je retourne chez mes parents
en Normandie, et arrive
le mouvement des gilets jaunes.
C'était le 17 novembre.
Et là, je vois arriver
sur les ronds-points
des gens que je connais,
des copains de collège, d'école,
et je vois, finalement,
tout un tas de gens
abstentionnistes militants
ou qui votent d'habitude pour le RN
ou pour les extrêmes
et qui se politisent
et viennent discuter
les uns avec les autres,
trouvent des solutions,
et quand ils se mettent ensemble,
ils parlent de pouvoir d'achat,
de nouvelles institutions
démocratiques,
pas d'immigration,
pas d'insécurité, pas d'islam.
J'ai vu une expérience
démocratique nouvelle,
que la gauche
n'a pas très bien saisie.
La gauche pensait
que c'était un mouvement
néo-poujadiste.
-Ca a été une révélation,
pour vous ?
-Oui, on a vu un peuple
à l'état brut
qui essayait de reprendre
la main sur son destin,
de retrouver le chemin
du collectif...
-De se repolitiser ?
-Oui,
au sens noble
du terme.
Ce qui s'est passé
est une grande leçon
pour nous, les politiques,
et doit nourrir la refondation
de la gauche
dans les années qui viennent.
-Sur ces ronds-points,
vous avez fait une rencontre
déterminante, Ingrid Levavasseur,
une figure des gilets jaunes.
Elle est à l'origine
de votre première
candidature à une élection ?
Vous avez été tête
de liste aux municipales avec elle
sur votre liste à Louviers.
-Absolument.
Ingrid, que je connais bien,
qui était au début du mouvement
sur le péage de Bouville,
qui est aussi
dans ma circonscription.
Et avec Ingrid, on a monté
cette liste aux municipales...
-Vous l'auriez fait sans elle ?
-Probablement, mais ça aurait été
totalement différent.
C'est une personnalité
très charismatique
avec une forte capacité
d'entraînement et qui a incarné
un combat central
qui est celui des femmes
monoparentales,
et aussi la question des soignants.
Elle était aide-soignante.
Avec son charisme
et sa détermination,
elle a donné une très belle image
de ce mouvement
qui a été dégradé
par les manifestations parisiennes.
Je distingue
les gilets jaunes des ronds-points
et les manifestations parisiennes,
qui ne correspondaient
pas au même esprit.
-Ces deux expériences,
les gilets jaunes
et cette liste aux municipales,
vont ont convaincu
qu'il fallait refonder la gauche.
Vous auriez pu théoriser ceci
en écrivant un livre.
Vous avez préféré
organiser une fête populaire
avec foire à tout,
barraques à frites
et autos-tamponeuses,
au milieu de tout ça,
discours de Philippe Brun.
La refondation de la gauche passe
par ce genre d'évènements ?
-Absolument.
La politique est une langue
étrangère
pour beaucoup de gens,
et les gens qui vont
aux réunions politiques
sont des gens déjà convaincus.
-Ce sont des militants.
-Oui, avec un fort capital culturel.
Et de fait,
nous faisons souvent
de la politique en chambre,
loin des préoccupations des gens.
J'ai essayé d'organiser
un rassemblement politique
sans militants déjà convaincus
Pour faire venir les gens,
il y avait une foire à tout.
Chez nous, ça veut dire "braderie",
ça n'existe qu'en Normandie.
Il y avait effectivement
des trampolines,
des barbes-à-papa, des frites.
-Et ça a marché ?
-Très bien.
On a fait venir plein de gens.
Plus de 500 personnes
ont écouté mon discours.
Il y avait des ateliers
sur le féminisme,
sur le monde du travail,
sur les retraites, la sécurité,
et pour moi,
c'est à ça que doit servir
un évènement politique populaire,
où des gens viennent, se politisent,
se rendent compte
que leurs colères sont partagées
et que quelque chose se passe
dans la société.
-Ce qui résume aussi
votre engagement,
c'est ce que vous avez appelé
l'école
de l'engagement,
que vous avez créée
avec Arnaud Montebourg
comme parrain de la toute
première promotion.
Ca aussi, c'est lié
à votre diagnostic
d'une gauche coupée du peuple ?
-Oui.
Aujourd'hui, 80 % des députés
sont cadres
alors que 80 % des Français
ne le sont pas.
Il n'y a plus que deux ou trois
ouvriers à l'Assemblée.
Il y en avait 50
dans les années 70.
La politique est devenue
une profession réglementée.
Il y a des gens sur le terrain
qui pourraient être députés
et représenter les autres...
-Donc l'idée est d'avoir
des élèves dans cette école
plus représentatifs
de la société ?
-Oui, les élèves
sont tous ouvriers, employés...
Vous avez des caissières,
des aides-soignantes,
opérateurs sur une plateforme
téléphonique... et ces gens-là
ont vocation à nous remplacer.
C'est ce que je porte fortement,
c'est qu'il y ait
à l'Assemblée au moins
40 % d'ouvriers et d'employés,
le principe de la parité populaire.
On a la parité femmes-hommes,
il faut encore des progrès.
Il faut aujourd'hui
qu'on ait au moins
40 % d'ouvriers et d'employés
à l'Assemblée.
Pendant les gilets jaunes,
sur les ronds-points,
il y avait des gens
qui s'exprimaient aussi bien
que les députés
et qui étaient aussi experts,
donc je préférerais les voir
représenter leurs concitoyens.
-Vous leur apprenez quoi ?
-C'est une école pour se donner
les clés pour s'engager.
Il y a des cours théoriques :
philo, histoire,
pour avoir des outils
de défense intellectuelle,
du droit, des finances publiques,
des savoirs techniques,
et des savoir-faire politiques :
comment monter une manifestation,
une pétition,
créer une mobilisation,
comment on fait
une campagne électorale.
Le but, à la fin, c'est d'être élu.
-Un ouvrier qui serait
sympathisant du RN
y aurait sa place ?
-Non, c'est une école
qui n'est pas partisane,
mais qui a un socle de valeurs.
On n'est pas là
pour former des députés RN
ou macronistes
mais des gens qui partagent
les valeurs de la gauche :
justice sociale, écologie
et nouvelles institutions
démocratiques.
-Votre travail à l'Assemblée
a pris une forme
assez originale,
avec ce que vous avez fait
sur le dossier EDF.
On vous a confié
une mission, vous avez interrogé,
on ne vous a pas répondu
et vous vous êtes
au ministère de l'Economie
et des Finances.
-Je suis venu
avec une administratrice
de la commission des finances
et nous avons recopié
sur des cahiers les documents
qui nous ont été montrés.
C'est un peu ridicule.
Là, on a
très mal aux poignets.
Jamais je n'aurais eu communication
des documents demandés,
mais nous devons réfléchir
à cette entrave aux libertés,
qui a été imposée
par le gouvernement
et qui est sans précédent
dans notre république.
-Ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est pas le fond du dossier
mais plutôt votre démarche.
Ca ressemble
presque à une perquisition,
c'est spectaculaire,
mais vous exercez là
un des pouvoirs de député.
-Oui, les députés
ont beaucoup de pouvoir
souvent non utilisés.
En tant que rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances,
c'est l'article de la loi
du 1er août 2001,
on a le droit de faire
des contrôles.
Dans le cadre
de la nationalisation d'EDF,
j'avais demandé
des documents
que le gouvernement
ne voulait pas me donner.
Donc je suis allé
à Bercy faire un contrôle sur pièce,
l'équivalent d'une perquisition,
et j'ai découvert
un plan caché
de procéder à un démantèlement d'EDF
après la montée
au capital.
-Les députés ont conscience
de tous leurs pouvoirs ?
Ils les exercent pleinement ?
-Parfois, ils ont peur :
"Comment je vais faire ?"
C'est pour ça : le savoir,
c'est le pouvoir.
L'école est là pour donner le savoir
de ce qu'on a le droit de faire.
Pas mal de collègues ont vu
ce que j'ai fait
et qui ont envie de le faire.
Si le gouvernement
m'avait donné
les documents...
-Vous n'auriez pas eu besoin
de recopier à la main,
comme vous l'avez fait.
C'est l'heure de notre quizz.
Le principe est simple.
Je vais lire le début d'une phrase
et ce sera à vous de la compléter.
Prêt ?
-C'est parti.
-Alors on y va.
-Les jeux de rôles.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-La politique devient souvent
un théâtre d'ombres.
Moi, je préfère
quand on dit ce qu'on pense
et inversement.
-"La dernière fois que j'ai croisé
Bruno Le Maire..."
-C'était probablement
à la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée.
-Ca se passe bien entre vous ?
Vous l'avez agacé avec votre
démarche sur le dossier EDF.
-Oui, bien sûr.
Ca se passe bien.
Il est ancien député de l'Eure,
territoires qui sont proches.
Sa circonscription
a basculé dans le camp
du Rassemblement national.
Il a été très peu coopératif
sur la question d'EDF.
J'ai évidemment du respect pour lui,
comme pour tous
les ministres.
-La suivante.
-Que les députés
avaient de la chance
d'être là, et...
-Vous rêviez
d'être député ?
-Un jour.
Je faisais pas de plan de carrière.
J'avais envie d'être juge,
et je suis devenu juge, ma passion.
Mais c'est vrai que j'avais
un peu ce rêve-là.
Et aujourd'hui, je suis pas déçu.
-Vous êtes pas déçu,
mais il y a des choses
qui vont ont surpris,
auxquelles vous ne vous attendiez
pas ?
-Non, ce qui a été vraiment
différent,
ce qui a changé dans ma vie,
c'est que localement,
le regard des gens a changé.
Avant, j'étais un peu
l'enfant du pays sympa
qui se présente :
"On va mettre un bulletin pour lui,"
"mais on croit pas en ses chances."
Dans notre territoire, la gauche
est de plus en plus absente,
le RN dévore...
-Vous êtes le seul député non RN
dans votre département.
-Oui.
Et cette victoire, oui, elle a donné
un nouveau statut à la gauche
dans mon territoire et à mes idées.
C'est cela qui a changé pour moi.
-C'est la fin de cette émission.
Merci beaucoup d'être venu
dans "La politique et moi".
SOUS-6ITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...